all right this is a candy crush soda
saga level 70 walkthrough with
commentary
um
i'm gonna play through this beginning
part kind of fast
because this is a level that you know
starts out with a lot of moves and takes
a lot of time
and i'm i'm making this because it's
going to go along with our written tips
and our guide so
you'll be able to read more about the
strategy there but basically what i'm
trying to do in the beginning is um it's
kind of like a combination between 40
and 60
and that you need to clear out the space
and then you're so that you can make big
combos that will actually
um
clear out the stuff you know the ice and
the blockers
so it's kind of like the worst of both
worlds kind of scenario
it's a tough level
so i'm going to like i said i'm just
going to play kind of fast in the
beginning and then when we get to the
more key decisions later
i'll go into a little more depth of what
i'm trying to do since right now there's
not a whole lot of space there's not a
lot of a lot of choices so
i'm basically just trying to
bust through the middle
if you can't go straight across i mean
that's the ideal if you can't do that it
is okay to to go down on either side
and
just because space is more important
than anything else you can't make you
can't make collarbones you can't make
coloring candies until you have enough
room to do that so
you know try to go this way but if you
can tell it's not working out then then
you have good ways to go down like i did
there and then just go ahead and do that
and i try to stay
on one side i don't i try not to uh
kind of move back and forth if i can
help it
until it makes sense to do that so
i mean i see that i have this match over
here but
i'll wait until
i don't have anything else going on in
this side
definitely look for setups like that you
know where you can put them together
wrap candies are probably the best
regular special candy that you can have
here so
definitely make those when you can
later you will need
the color bombs and the um
coloring candies but in the beginning
the wrap candy does the best as far as
clearing out that space
all right so here we have
a striped candy going down
we have the gap for
a color bomb
or we can just
bust out the center
i think i like busting out the center
just because that'll stay in place and
it might you know you might get the
color you need to pop in there
and um
that stripe isn't going to change things
all that much
but now that we have that middle part
cut out we can you know get a little bit
more of a chance of the cascade
and that's really what we're looking for
is more more chances to
make the big ones
all right so
seems like that went really fast but now
we're down to
16 moves and we still have 11 more bears
to find
all right so that is why you
can't really expect
to complete this level without combos
there's just too many bears and too much
in the way of blockers and things like
that so you
so you need
it's not that you just would like to
make them you actually need
big combos
so now that we have like pretty much the
whole side cleared out over here that's
what we're going to do is look for
places where we can set up
some big combos
if you played this level a few times
already then you know that you're not
always going to get what you want
i don't particularly need this fish at
all but
it will move things down a little bit
maybe shake things up at the top
same here like
activating that fish basically does
nothing but
now we can set up a color bomb right
here by making a stripe right here
so you know when all else fails
set up a cascade
so you know the color bomb is not going
to do anything just by
firing those off
you know just by taking out one of the
colors i mean it would help a little bit
and that it or you know would clear out
part of
one color that would give us a higher
chance of matching
a special boat
we basically need specials right now
there we go that's a good one
and i don't know if i said this i played
this a couple times but that's one of
the things you really have to keep in
mind here is that this level almost
always gets finished at the end so
and it really changes as far as like
what's available when you get towards
you
so you never want to really give up on
this one
because with one big combo
you know you can almost
you can almost um
finish
so here we are we have
a lot of pieces
and we only have two moves so
from a quick
look
it appears that making this color bomb
and then taking out red
might get us where we need to go
and honestly
with only two moves i don't think
there's anything better we can do except
for try that
i'm not 100 sure
if i'm going to get it because it's
going to take a little bit of luck but
that's really the best choice so let's
try it
and it did so that's how you do it
and like i said hang in there to the end
because it can take that but you see
just by following the tips i mean
clear out space look for big combos we
were down to what three or four moves
there
and we were able to get it
through one really big combo
and um
that's what you have to do so
hope you liked the video i hope it helps
um
feel free to leave a comment if you have
questions
make sure you check out our site
candycrushsodasagatips.com
to learn all about the game and find our
level index
please subscribe to our channel to
support the work that we do
and we'll be making new videos soon
thanks